hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
to reason [ __ ] calm when we give you
reasons to see and not to see the hobbit
an unexpected journey Ryan's consensus I
would have to say there are a few strong
reasons to watch the hobbit there are a
few strong reasons to see the hobbit I
was uh I'm baffled by how disappointed I
am I can't even quite put my opinion
into words it's a good thing we're about
to talk about yeah Jerry's consensus um
yeah I think there are few strong
reasons to see this movie there are a
few strong reasons to see The Hobbit you
know I'm sort of having trouble figuring
out how I felt him probably a little bit
it's all kind of them it's like there's
so much stuff that I'm having trouble
processing and so all this might change
but as of now there at least a few
strong reasons reason to see number one
Martin Freeman Morgan Freeman was great
really ya know I made the way he
narrated all those scenes you know yeah
he was fantastic I thought he was
actually oh he was well cast it took a
while for him to find his groove in it I
think but eventually when it when he
likes settled into the performance I
thought he did a top-notch job I think
it's better than old would look see
Martin Freeman was like when they said
they were doing this movie in the back
of my mind I was like I hope they get
Martin Freeman and then when they did I
was psyched and you know to bike I'm not
just saying this cuz I like Martin
Freeman like he was the perfect Bilbo
for this story to me yet he does a good
job on the acting you mean he's charming
in it he's funny Bilbo at this point his
life and at this point in story like
it's different from a lot of the Rings
and I thought he really captured that
sort of like befuddled essence the Bilbo
has and then as time goes on you know he
has some great scenes where he actually
starts genome man of you know and I
didn't even realize it so right now at
this very moment but he does do a good
job
on the growth in the movie yeah because
he does have a character arc in the film
and now that I look back on it he's very
believable it throughout the whole park
it's not like he transforms into a
different person by the end and it's
like well yeah hell I just felt like he
had he had a really rich life about him
like just the way he behaved and his
mannerisms and stuff like I really liked
all that stuff reason to see number two
Ian McKellen and Gandalf the Grey or as
some people call him Gandalf the gay
because his yay he's gay hate your life
that's good gay nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with being gay but he's
back and he's rocking it again you know
he i could see him as magneto a billion
times and I could see him as Gandalf a
billion times and he's always gonna be
solid and it's called the scene you know
fighting and kicking some ass you know
when he shows up with the sword and his
his staff you know you say he's pretty
cool for an old dude ya know he goes he
makes old dudes you know pretty badass
you know I didn't see her that day I
think the AARP should count themselves
lucky yeah gay old dudes are the way to
go yeah yeah high five for Gail inhibit
his reason to see number three Gollum so
Smeagol / golem is back and wow that's
probably my favorite part of the whole
movie to be honest I gotta set you know
like to me that scene was worth the
price of admission and i paid like
twenty dollars to see this in like all
the all the bells and whistles that
seemed blew my mind how much I enjoyed
that scene and don't get us wrong I know
we're saying it's a scene but it's a
long scene yeah it is long like it could
have been longer for my taste yeah I
would have liked to see Colin coming
earlier like it's an ink rely Andy
Serkis is incredible in that scene and
the weight like he and Martin Freeman
play off each other so well mmm and like
someone's gotta give andy serkis some
kind of award because like that dude is
is acting well yes and it's incredible
it's it's a great performance and it's
like he's nailing it he's not just
putting on his little Gollum half that
he's doing yeah strong performance that
he's givin ya on it and it's the best
like like I I was blown away partly to
because like the the way they realized
golub they gave him more facial muscles
and like just the effects on him and
everything
our great like oh I really believed he
was there it was incredible he brings
back that that Flair that the Rings
trilogy had I just remember watching
Gollum in the two towers yeah and he's
funny he's scary he's creepy to care
about him you don't care about is you
always got mixed emotions about the guy
he's the most complex character to watch
and he once again he just pulled it off
top-notch man I I'm having a nice rich
to ever play a human being he should
just stick to doing what he's doing yeah
there's cool to see how we lost the ring
you know it's one of those pretty cool
cool moments to see that but like that
scene is responsible for the entire lore
of the Radia reason to seat number for
visual and special effects I broke new
ground for me especially in these
fantasy film films because I'm watching
it and the trolls look real every guy
all the special effects most of the time
it looked very real yeah they improved
on golem they approved on all the
creatures from before it's fantastic
trolls talking and it's believable when
you're watching it just because of how
great the visual effects actually are oh
yeah I mean there's a really good
balance between you know practical
effects and CG and everything for the
most part blends really well it's used
really well and everything looks real
like like that rock giant battle yes I
was so I was like whoa like that was
another one's mind blowing mom it's like
with any cg heavy movie they're gonna be
a couple times where things don't look
quite on it but for the most part in
this movie like barring a couple scenes
like the the visual effects were Chris I
saw it in 3d and I was like this is my
impression of 3d by the way binocular
binoculars that's how I watched oh it's
like an old Isis screen so far away
reason to see number 5 hair and makeup
design I mean not only where the visual
effects good too but the actual like
hair makeup design as well it was also
top-notch yeah it's good to point that
out because that's a that's part of how
you're able to tell the dwarves of
Barca's are so many dwarves yeah and you
know like they all have varying degrees
of importance in terms of the
it's nice that you can tell that oh that
guy has the braided mustache that's the
guy with the weird hair yeah the cut cuz
the costumes are all great the makeup
looks very real on everyone the air
design you know it's weird talking my
hair design but it's not like they just
combed everyone's hair for this movie
they they have to do a lot of fig Ludwig
fictional here in this film reason to
see number six cinematography granted
I'm saying they're just a few reasons to
watch this but if you're someone who's
just really into like technical stuff
such as like the visual effects and
everything if the film does look really
good you know it's clear that they love
the stuff they get to play with because
they really take advantage of shooting
those you know locations and those
creatures and costumes and everything
and they do the cinematography helps
communicate the epic scope of everything
this film was shot in 48 frames per
second yeah and a lot of people are not
digging it no a lot of people hey a lot
of people are getting mad angry they're
yeah they're like it's too clear what
the hell Hollywood stop forcing me to
watch your weird movie look it's clear
yeah it is clear it's really you know I
think people on the hating on the 48
frames per second just because it's
different it's even have to adjust your
eyes to it you know 19 or whatever it
was in the beginning and now 24 frames
per second for so long but it is what we
associate with movies so you know it is
a shift after so long you know and I get
it you know a lot of people were like oh
looks like a BBC special thing but I
think it's the sort of thing where it's
like if tomorrow everything switched to
48 in a couple months we'd probably be
used we would readjust yeah because I
mean for me you know it's like I was
curious to check it out and honestly i'm
not i'm not just saying like honestly it
only took me about five or ten minutes
to get used to the look and after that I
really liked I actually really like this
just like watching really good blu-ray
yeah it's like at the beginning like he
puts down a book or something I was like
Watto that seem fair but it wasn't fast
I guess you know it has this this weird
sort of sped up and slowed down off the
same time quality for the first couple
minutes but once you get used to it I
actually thought it was cool and the
only I only have one complaint about it
and that would be that there were
certain moments in really CGI heavy
scenes where it was mostly cg creatures
and lots of camera motions those few
moments looked kind of like video game
cutscenes to me yeah yeah like you know
like when the dwarves are falling down
and rolling down to the Iranian recent
see number 7 set design it's great to
see Peter Jackson taking this back you
know to returning to middle-earth make a
new zealand take a that's where it takes
place even is middle-earth yeah it's
basically who heard it is fun i think
they just build the sets and were like
[ __ ] it we're leaving is here i think
that is actually what happened with so
they i'm not even kidding they clearly
pay attention to the drawings and stuff
or at least the ones I've seen and you
know you see places like Rivendell and
you see you know the inside of the
Dwarven mines and stuff in it's like
whoa yeah they revisit some familiar
places that we saw in the prior trilogy
and they've even updated the set designs
of all of them the routes on the little
auto-lock seal it's great to see dwarves
kicking some ass you know yeah I would
like to see the real life couple of
doors and uh and two other midgets
styles just a lot of small Carrie yeah
just like fighting and not characters
I'm talking like we do black people yeah
did fight tour fights calm or something
that's no guarantee website kidding yeah
forget movie review so we're just gonna
make a little people to fight each other
it'll be good yeah but the action does
look good even in the phonetic the third
act as a lot of action going on yeah it
does uh you know all the action scenes
ringing on the scope is spectacular and
just like you know it's big army
clashing it's big army and all these
like all the action is well done it's
well capture it all looks great I almost
feel like at some points there is almost
a little too much for my taste but just
for what the action scenes were like
they're all good
really i thought the phone was actually
at its best when there was action yeah
well they're like i said there's there's
certainly some action scenes are really
appreciated but towards the third act i
was kind of like we're hopping from like
one action scene to the next section
seem to the next action scene Jared
you're not getting it the action is the
best part of the movie ryan right if i
actually like some of the talk no Jerry
you're not getting your opinion is wrong
okay your personal feeling is yeah
change your feelings on the mare
reaction to this to this abstract piece
of art you know it's intangible things